في اطار حديثنا حول اكبر سنه في عمر 79
عاما
الممثل والمخرج الامريكي روبرتنيرو استقبل
مولوده مولوده السابع
جنيرو مشاهدينا اكد الخبر لكن دون اعطاء
اي تفاصيل حيث لا يزال جنس المولود وهويه
والدته مجهوله
هذا الحائز على جائزه الاوسكار هو ايضا
والد الممثله درينا دينيرو التي تبلغ من
العمر 51 عاما وايضا ابن رافاييل البالغ
من العمر 46 عام من زوجته الاولى طبعا اما
من زوجته الثانيه فلديه توام جوليا وارن
واليت وهما في سن العشرينيات والطفله
هالاندريس
طيب
الانجاب في عمر متاخر طبعا هذه
المواهب تستمر في الانتاج بالنسبه لينيرو
ولكن خلونا
نقول بانه يعني هذا الانسان اعطى الكثير
لكن الى الان حياته الشخصيه
ما زال لم يفصح الكثير عنها مش كثير
معلوماتي
تعدد زوجات اطفال كثير طبعا ما عندهم اي
مشاكل ماديه عندهم مشاكل نفسيه انا مشاكل
نفسيه
يعني على ما يبدو وانا بنحزله 79 يلا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات